morning
hay cakes are perfect this time okay
[Music]
you
what are you nothing go back to bed I'm
just making some breakfast
like I can't go to sleep after the stall
shudders coffee so I see you don't know
your way around the kitchen
what's happening I was thinking that we
could have breakfast together right
everybody coming in hot we got our first
trailer for the flash arrow Elseworlds
crossover Oliver wakes up in Burien
Iris's loft
iris wakes him calls him Barry Allen
says she made perfect pancakes so you
know something's up in proceeds to plant
a fat one right on his lips in the whole
time Oliver has that look on his face of
horror like what the hell is going on
here we're doing a new round of the
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment about the trailer on the video
mostly freaking out about what's going
on just like Oliver but the footage in
the way iris talks the things that she
says gives you all the clues you need to
understand what the mechanics are of
them body swapping because in this
version of reality our earth-1 Oliver
Queen's mind is the same you can tell
from the look on his face he knows he's
not in the right place like why am I in
Barry's loft and why is his wife kissing
me this isn't wife swap Elseworlds
edition but he's got Barry's powers as
the flash and it's as if his entire life
has been swapped for Barry's so everyone
else on earth one thinks that he is
Barry Allen
so this twisty Oliver version of Barry
grew up in the same house with Iris the
same thing happened his mother was
murdered by the reverse-flash but as I
said the big Easter egg here and the
reason why I attacked that pancake scene
odd is because we learned a couple
episodes ago that iris is a terrible
cook Nora even tells us that in the
future 30 plus years she still can't
cook pancakes what are you doing I am
just getting evidence that you make
pancakes in every time period so part of
the fun of watching the crossover is
just seeing what's different in this new
version of reality but it's the same
deal for earth-1 berry he's probably now
waking up either in prison maybe or
maybe Oliver gets out of prison on the
aero TV show before the crossover so
that when berry wakes up in Oliver place
it's the same scenario it's Felicity
planning if that went on his lips saying
all right what are we gonna go do today
and him just freaking out like why is
Felicity kissing me what's going on one
of the biggest questions that people
were asking the producers when they
first announced this was going to be
Elseworlds because that title is very
important was whether or not it would be
canon to what's happening in the
arrowverse were if these episodes for
the crossover would just be set in a
different universe so they didn't need
to address the continuity of what's
going on each week on the shows this
year mark Dugan Haim revealed this is
canon so this is earth one Oliver and
earth one Barry that people are messing
with a good example of comic book
Elseworlds is Gotham by Gaslight they
just turned that into an animated movie
it's basically the story of Batman done
during the time of Jack the Ripper in
Victorian London the stars of the show
have been referring to it as a Freaky
Friday situation but I don't know if
that means that when Oliver looks into a
mirror at himself he sees Barry or if he
looks like this all the time the cause
of the switch seems like it's most
likely the special book we've seen black
suit Superman reading from before all
the heroes tread snatch it away from him
and fight him down we'll probably get
some of those scenes in one of the
future crossover trailers like the
trailer says it's not coming for several
weeks so there'll be a bunch more
trailers for this but we've already seen
a poster of the monitor holding that
special book so maybe this is a scenario
where black suits Superman steals it
from him it seems like it has Nora's
special speedforce symbols and but
there's also some other writing that
looks a little Kryptonian
so maybe the monitor just has a book
that holds the power to rewrite the
multiverse in reality in black suits
Superman lost his Lois Lane or something
terrible happened in his University
wants to change it so that serves as the
motivation for why you would want to
switch reality like this isn't just
somebody having fun because this black
suit Superman seems like the most
hardcore version
Superman we've ever seen on the TV show
if you've never read crisis on Infinite
Earths or you've never read Infinite
Crisis which was sort of the big event
after that you have one character or a
group of characters in some cases trying
to rewrite the multiverse to bring back
something that they lost from their
reality there's that initial scene from
the flash that I'll play in a second
from episode one this season where they
refer to Nora's future newspaper you see
all this text referring to psycho-pirate
and all these characters from the
original crisis on Infinite Earths
you never come back so it seems like
that's the event that they're building
out towards in a future season but
because we have to monitor and we have
all these ride waging consequences it
seems like we're going there faster than
we ever thought for every reaction there
has to be some equal and opposite
reaction so monitor existing means that
the anti-monitor exists in the
antimatter universe hopefully we'll get
a teaser for that at the end of this but
that's still speculation right now they
said that it's gonna get really weird
they'll be crazy comic book Easter eggs
like the 90s version of Barry Allen we
don't know where he comes from if he's
from a different universe or if because
black suits Superman is rewriting
reality this is just him rewriting this
version of Jay Garrick or he rewrites
something else and the butterfly effect
is the reason why all these other things
are changing so it's not really clear if
he is targeting barry in oliver and
switching them specifically or if he has
changed something else about reality and
Barry and Oliver switching places in
their lives and timelines is just a
consequence of that we know that Lois
Lane and regular Superman from Earth 38
are big characters we go there we've
seen scenes on the Kent farm remember
big Easter Egg is that they're filming
the Kent farm scenes on the same Kent
farm that they used for the Smallville
TV show so it doesn't totally canonize
Smallville but it's like the next
closest thing you could get without
actually having Tom Welling show up in a
Superman suit we haven't seen any
footage of her but Stephen amell's wife
in real life is playing Nora fries and
obviously the other big thing happening
in all this that we haven't seen footage
of yet is them introducing the bat woman
character the Gotham that she is from
like these are the sets that they've
shot for that it looks really rundown
things have gone to crap
so wherever she's from maybe something
terrible happened in that universe in
that's where black suits Superman is
from like maybe he and Superman never
came together maybe it's like a darkest
timeline Batman V Superman pre history
situation but it definitely seems like
he's going to be the backdoor villain of
this crossover unless there's someone in
the shadows pulling the strings that
created the circumstances that led
Superman to make these choices we have
seen pictures of two different versions
of Superman going at each other so it
does seem like our
hoechlin earth 38 Superman is a
different character from the black suit
Superman so that's why I think he's from
a darkest timeline scenario universe but
what'll happen is is because Stan Lee
passed away and I wanted to do the
memorial video I'm behind on arrow in
the so I probably won't do an arrow
episode video this week believe all your
requests in the comments below
rag doll is coming to the flash episode
and there was a Ryan Reynolds detective
Pikachu trailer that dropped and
obviously because of all the stuff was
Stanley happened today I had to push
that but leave all your requests in the
comments below click here for my Stan
Lee memorial video and click here for my
last big flash trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome see
you guys tonight
[Music]
you